[Musique]
nous allons donc parler à présent de ces
élections professionnelles dans les TPE
les très petites entreprises auparavant
Michel schafner j'aimerais votre
réaction en tant que syndicaliste CGT
également on vient d'entendre l'un de
vos collègu de la CGT mobilisé sur le
site d'Alcatel Lucent à véisi plus
globalement plus généralement est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet à la CGT pour la
situation de l'emploi dans le
département et bien d'abord je crois que
les les salariés d'Alcatel ont raison
hein de se mobiliser de lutter
euh le il y a un vrai problème dans les
Yvelines euh dans le au plan national
mais dans les Yvelines un problème par
rapport à l'avenir de l'industrie on a
besoin d'industrie l'industrie alimente
les service public alimente l'ensemble
de l'économie du pays c'est un moteur de
l'économie et nous effectivement on
pense que chaque fois qu'on perd de
l'industrie chaque fois qu'on supprime
des emplois et bien c'est des risques de
désindustrialisation mais aussi
d'affaiblir lire le le tissu économique
du département Michel chafner
responsable de la vie syndicale à la CGT
des evelines est l'invité de ce 78 pour
débuter cette édition du 8 novembre on
va parler donc de ces élections
professionnelles avant que vous nous
expliquz en quoi elles sont importantes
un chiffre va apparaître à l'écran 11
pour que ce soit bien clair c'est le
nombre maximal de salariés d'une très
petite entreprises une TPE concernée par
ces élections professionnelles s'il y a
moins de 11 salariés dans votre
entreprise vous êtes concerné ça se
déroule du 28 novembre au 12 décembre et
cette première question question
pourquoi allz voter pourquoi c'est
important ben c'est important déjà par
rapport au nombre de salariés concernés
hein c'est un salarié sur 5 en France
c'est-à-dire ça fait 4,5 million de
salariés 1 million en île-de-fance et
entre 80000 et 100000 dans les ivelines
donc c'est un enjeu énorme et la
deuxième raison ce sont des salariés qui
jusqu'à maintenant n'ont jamais pu
participer à des élections
professionnelles il n'ont jamais voté
hein pour des élections professionnelles
donc là ils ont une occasion il faut
qu'il profite de leur possibilité pour
pouvoir exprimer un choix à quoi servent
ces élections professionnelles en
êtes-vous déjà bien conscient nous
sommes allés vous poser la question
aujourd'hui on vous
écoute à élir des représentants de
corporation et est-ce que ça sert
vraiment à quelque chose par les temps
qui
cour la réponse je pense est dans mon
silence ça permet de lire les
représentants des salariés dans les
différents conseils style prudom Chambre
de commerce et d'industrie mais ntant
étant dans la fonction publique j'ai
assez peu de connaissance de ce système
là c'est essentiel par rapport à la
représentation au sein du travail par
les défenses des droits et
euh professionnel normalement c'est ce
sont les syndicats ce sont des gens qui
qui représentent les salariés
normalement il faut quand même que tout
le monde soit au courant de de de des
lois et PU puis il faut il faut que tout
le monde soit aidé donc les gens qui
sont spécialisés là-dedans sont quand
même informés et ils savent de quoi ils
parlent donc c'est important oua oui
mais pour moi c'est du passé dans ma vie
professionnelle j'ai pas eu à m'en
servir heureusement mais j'ai connu des
cas de figure où les prud d'hommes ont
longtemps réfléchi avant de prendre une
décision qui qui pouvait être prise le
jour même on parle de ces élections
justement elles vont servir à quoi on va
é lire qui et pourquoi et bien ces
élections vont permettre aux salariés
pour la première fois d'élire pour les
syndicats qu'ils choisissent pour les
représenter alors
effectivement on le sait euh les
syndicats participent aux négociations
sur les conventions collectives sur les
accords interprofessionnel sur l'égalité
hommes-femme donc c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est important ils auront la
possibilité donc de choisir euh en
votant CGT hein euh ben ils choisiront
un syndicat euh sur lesquels ils auront
ils onurt choisi un Sicap pour pour qu'
porteront leur revendication leur
revendication c'est quoi ben il y a eu
un sondage qui a été fait par la CGT
avec un institut qui dit que ils
estiment que leur salaire est
insuffisant ils estiment qu'ils ont
besoin de plus d'évolution
professionnelle donc c'est pour ces
choseslà qu'ils vont voter et l'autre
enjeu c'est la participation voilàin
nous on pense qu'il faut vraiment faire
connaître ces élections parce que il
faut qu'il y ait une bonne partici
passion pour que ça puisse peser à
l'avenir et vous puissiez vous faire
entendre on l'a entendu en tout cas l'un
de vos points de de programme c'était
effectivement l'occasion de le
mentionner alors c'est un scrutin inedy
on l'a dit et la particularité c'est
qu'on votera pour un syndicat pas pour
des candidats aussi hein voilà on votera
pour un pour un syndicat euh donc donc
l'une des huit organisations syndicales
nationales et puis il y en a d'autres
aussi qui existent en fonction des des
branches de chacune des entrepris ex
exactement hein donc ben nous ce qu'on
pense hein et ce qu'on dit au salariés
c'est d'une part aller voter c'est
important et d'autre part de choisir des
syndicats et ben qu'il connaissent euh
qui ont du répendant hein euh la CGT
c'est le premier syndicat en France
c'est le premier syndicat dans les
ivelines euh je pense que c'est
important que les salariés reportent
leur choix sur des syndicats Ben qui ont
la capacité d'agir de négocier pour eux
oui parce qu'il y a un point qui est
très important c'est que ces syndicats
et ces élections vont permettre aux
syndicats en tout cas de d'imposer ou
non leur point de vue d'être
représentatif parce que ça découle d'une
réforme on va rentrer un petit peu dans
le détail tout à l'heure mais déjà dans
les grandes lignes il faut que les gens
se déplacent massivement pour aller
voter quel que soit le syndicat que que
vous choisirez pour qu'en tout cas les
syndicats est un poid ensuite pour
discuter absolument hein il faut savoir
que ces élections vont contribuer à la
représentativité syndicale donc il y a
déjà un certain nombre d'élections
professionnelles des entreprises de plus
de 11 salariés qui contribuent ces
élections vont contribuer pour les
entreprises les TPE donc de moins de 11
salariés et ça va établir la
représentation nationale des syndicats
mais également par branche hein donc
elle revê une très grande importance
hein c'est pour définir la
représentativité effectivement il y a il
y a trois étapes hein il y a ce vote
pour les entreprise de moins de 11
salariés pour cell de plus de 11
salariés ce sont les résultats des
élections des membres des comités
d'entreprise des délégués du personnel
qui seront prises en compte et puis il y
aura ensuite un troisème point une
troisième étape les suffrages qui seront
exprimés en janvier lors des élections
aux Chambres départementale
d'agriculture ensuite il y a un point
global qui sera fait et ces syndicats
pour être jugés représentatif devront
avoir atteint 8 % au minimum des
suffrages exprimés est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour la CGT s'il n'y a pas une
mobilisation assez forte de voir que les
8 % sont difficiles à atteindre en tout
en tout cas nous on travaille à à cette
participation cette mobilisation
euh on on mène une campagne alors il
faut savoir hein que les salariés qui
sont concernés ce sont des salariés de
l'artisanat mais ce sont aussi des
assistantes maternelles dans les ivelin
nous avons créé un syndicat d'assistant
maternel CGT justement pour qu'elle
puisse se défendre ce sont les salariés
de salon de coiffure de commerce et
cetera et le commerce représente une
grosse partie de ce salariat dans les
ivelines et notamment la moitié des
salariés TP de commerce sont sur poissi
versaill 5 en iveline donc nous allons
vers eux parce que nous pensons que le
premier enjeu c'est déjà effectivement
la participation à ce vote 4,6 millions
de salariés des TPE qui sont donc
appelés à voter du 28 novembre au 12
décembre pour l'un des syndicats de leur
choix euh concrètement comment on vote
et bien il y a deux possibilités de
voter donc le vote a lieu comme vous
l'avez dit hein du 28 novembre au 12
décembre et à partir du 15 novembre les
salariés vont commencer à recevoir leur
matériel électoral alors matériel
électoral entre guillemets parce que ça
sera les informations pour qu'il puisse
voter soit par internet soit par
correspondance hein donc nous les
appelons à voter le plus rapidement
possible de pas oublier hein voilà il
faut savoir qu'on a des ion locale CGT
qui feront des journées portes ouvertes
de vote CGT et de vote en tout cas au
moins et donc nous on va tout mettre en
œuvre pour qu'il y ait une bonne
participation à ces élections en tout
cas je rappelle ce chiffre 4,6 million
de salariés des TPE au niveau national
dans les evelines ils sont combien dans
les evelines ils sont entre 80 et 100000
et vous arrivez à tous les les toucher à
vous adresser à chacun comment vous
faites justement pour savoir qui est
salarié dans quelle entreprise vous
savez on invente un peu parce que c'est
une forme de de déploiement qu'on ne
connaissait pas forcément avant oui
parce que c'est une première soci voilà
donc elles sont plusieurs dizaines de
milliers c'est C TPE donc il est pas
concevable d'aller dans chacune d'entre
elles euh donc on va dans les centres
villees commerçants on a on s'est
déployé avec le bus infudroit CGT à
Versailles ce bus aonné toute la France
et il finit dans l'île de- France hein
euh on a fait des déploiements dans le
centre-ville bien sûr de Versailles je
l'ai dit mais aussi de Saint-Germain de
guilloncour prochainement de M repas
prochainement euh on va au contact de
ses salariés et pour tout vous dire on
est très bien reçu et on est
agréablement surpris par la manière dont
ils nous reçoivent et si cette élection
est une première c'est tout simplement
c'est la loi du 20 août 2008 portant la
rénovation du dialogue social qui a mis
en place cette élection notamment est-ce
que vous jugez que c'est une bonne
réforme cette rénovation du dialogue
social avec ces nouveaux critères pour
la représentativité des syndicats vous
savez tout ce qui favorise la
participation des syndicats des
élections va dans le bon sens pour nous
c'est insuffisant on aurait préféré
qu'il ait une élection sur des
candidatures sur des noms plutôt que sur
des sigles euh on n' pas pu l'avir mais
c'est en tout cas une avancé parce que
ces salariés qui n'ont souvent ont peu
de droit que dans les grandes
entreprises qui ne connaissent pas le
syndicalisme qui sont souvent dans la
précariité qui ont des plus petits
salaires que les autres et bien pour la
première fois ils pourront se faire
entendre hein donc c'est une occasion
c'est de la démocratie aussi c'est une
occasion unique qu'ils ont enfin unique
pas unique parce que nous espérons
qu'elle sera renouvelée enfin c'est le
sens de l'histoire en tout cas et que
cette
démocra cette démocratie cette
démocratie
euh le sens de l'histoire c'est vers la
démocratie sociale donc voilà ils ont
l'occasion de le faire hein euh il y a
un site CGT où il peuvent trouver
beaucoup d'informations donc je vais
donner le nom du site hein je les incite
à se connecter c'est TPE
2012.cgt.fr où ils pourront trouver un
certain nombre d'informations et et y
compris les revendications de la CGT et
donc de votre syndicat et puis les
autres syndicats aussi ont leur site
internet et puis il y a le site he du
ministère du Travail si vous voulez des
informations d'ordre plus général sur le
déroulement de ce vote et sur le le
pourquoi de ces élections dans les TPE
merci Michel schafner responsable de la
vie syndicale à la CGT des ivelin d'être
venu en plateau je rappelle les dates
hein de ce scrutin 28 novembre au 12
décembre et puis si vous faites partie
des 4,6 millions de salariés concernés
que vous n'avez pas eu les informations
que vous ne les avez pas reçu à votre
domicile on vous renvoie on vous incite
à vous rendre sur le site internet du
ministère du Travail
la suite du 78 de ce 8 novembre réalisé
en direct entre 18 et 19h avec ce
reportage de Joann sououdri et de
Guillaume camps qui va vous prouver que
l'opéra c'est aussi dès le plusun âge
c'est en ce moment sur les planches du
Théâtre national à saint-qutin
en voilà sujet reportage sur l'opéra à
50 ans en Eveline qui est aussi pour les
plus
jeunes il était une fois un petit garçon
appelé Momo qui vivait dans un cirque
c'est une histoire simple mais en même
temps qui est important c'est que un
enfant qui à qui on dit voilà bah il va
il va prendre la la relève de son
grand-père il sera clown et lui son
souhait c'est d'être
acrobate je ne veux pas être un clown
sanglotail je n'aime pas les
clown tout ce qu'il veut c'est faire une
c'est être acrobate donc pas du tout ce
qui a été prévu pour lui quoi et il va
il va donc
devoir se battre contre ce grand-père
et et arriver à à lui faire entendre que
c'est vraiment acrobate qui veut être et
ce que le grand-père doit reconnaître à
la fin quoi Momo commença à se balancer
dans les airs d'avant en arrière
d'arrière en avant d'avant en
arrièrereant à l'origine de Momo un
livre disque pour enfant sorti en 19 96
les morceaux sont signés Pascal du sapin
compositeur
contemporain c'est un spectacle qu'on a
créé il y a 10 ans exactement là
quasiment jour pour jour en novembre
2002 tout cet univers du cirque est
vraiment traité de façon poétique que ce
soit donc avec les animaux qu'on voit
derrière ce cyclo les éléments comme ça
qui qui font partie du cirque de
d'acrobatie et cetera et le clown bien
sûr euh c'est c'est vrai qu'en même
temps c'est assez simple et il y a
beaucoup de ça traverse pas mal de
choses quoi la musique le cirque le jeu
et le théâtre d'ombre sans oublier
l'interactivité avec le jeune public et
la sensibilisation aux instruments de
musique comme la clarinette la mandoline
ou le violon sel Momo un spectacle
musical àiant humour et poésie avoir au
théâtre de Saint-Quentin vendrredi 9 et
samedi 10
novembre